incluso antes de iniciar su sexto
mandato todo un récord benjamine tanyao
trató de calmar las preocupaciones
acerca de su nuevo gobierno formado por
su partido o conservador licut partidos
Ultra ortodoxos y una facción religiosa
ultranacionalista extrema derecha
afiliada al movimiento de colonos de
cisjordania la colonia en el país que
dirigiré no habrá ninguna situación en
la que una persona ya sea lgbtq árabe
Ultra ortodoxa o cualquier otra entre en
un hotel y no reciba servicio o entra en
la consulta de un médico y no reciba
servicio
pero varios de sus nuevos aliados de
coalición son abiertamente anti lgbtq
han agitado contra los derechos de las
minorías o han pedido la anexión
completa de cisjordania entre ellos y
tomar vengavir del partido poder judío
que vive en las disjordania ocupada y
fue condenado en 2007 por incitación
contra los árabes está a cargo de la
policía en el nuevo Ministerio de
seguridad
con la ayuda de Dios formaremos Un
gobierno totalmente de derechas
otro color nueces Jordania el líder del
sionismo religioso besalel smotrich será
ministro de finanzas pero también tendrá
autoridad sobre la expansión de los
asentamientos judíos en las disjordania
ocupada
alrededor de 500.000 colonos judíos
viven en territorios que los palestinos
reclaman como estado ocupación que la
comunidad internacional considera ilegal
y un obstáculo para la paz a pesar de
ello el partido de netaniagua firmó en
una declaración de prioridades políticas
que el nuevo gobierno perseguirá la
expansión de los asentamientos una
amenaza que corre el riesgo de aumentar
la violencia en los territorios ocupados
tras un aumento de los disturbios este
año el más mortífero desde 2006